привіт і Ласкаво просимо на програму
Європи У фокусі Ми раді що ви
приєдналися до нас в Україні Контрнаступ
проти російської окупації повільно
просувається вперед
повідомляється про запеклі бої особливо
навколо міста Бахмут на сході країни
президент України Зеленський відвідав
там війська наприкінці липня місто було
зруйноване і захоплене російськими
військами на початку травня
наразі обидві сторони зазнають значних
втрат в боротьби за Бахмут
щоб компенсувати втрати необхідно
постійно набирати і тренувати нове
солдатів деякі з них навіть проходять
підготовку безпосередньо перед лінією
фронту один з українських тренувальних
таборів розташований поблизу бахмута де
російський опір особливо сильний тут
командири рот повинні працювати над тим
щоб інтегрувати новоприбуток у свої
підрозділи щодня вони стикаються з
надзвичайно небезпечними ситуаціями не
лише для себе але для новобранців наш
кореспондент та його команди пережили це
на власному досвіді коли відвідали
навчальний підрозділ
це момент коли Атака вщухає вона вдарили
російські касетні бомби усі ховаються де
тільки можна Коли все стихає Ми
намагаємося вибратися звідти
ми приїхали не задовго до цього щоб
зняти навчання солдатів які вступають до
розвідувального взводу
більшість із них новобранці деякі
солдати переведені із інших підрозділів
серед завдань взводу вогневе прикриття
так та вилозок
найактивніше зазвичай і отримують
поранення і гинуть ну тобто випадають зі
строю на певний час довгий да тому
доводиться доводиться брати людей аби
зберігати боєздатність підрозділу знову
навчатись з тими людьми які на
сьогоднішній день залишається в строю і
продовжувати нашу боротьбу
хоча офіційних даних немає очевидно що
втрати наразі високі
за кілька кілометрів звідси піхотинці
вчаться штурмувати ворожі окопи хвиля
добровольців що вступають до армії
спадає натомість набирають все більше
призовників потреба у доукомплектуванні
підрозділів дуже велика
мобілізовані проходять елементарну
підготовку а потім поспіхом готуються до
виконання своїх обов'язків
Соловей такий позивний цього бійця був
призваний два місяці тому
треба більше
навчатися
у нас же ж така ситуація що все
розвалилася А тепер треба бистро бистро
бистро
вперед вперед
штурм ворожих позицій одна з
найнебезпечніших операцій в окопній
війні
у військах кажуть що перша атака солдата
найнебезпечніша І що майже ніхто не
залишається неушкодженим після трьох
Атак
класно
мінометами Тебе накриває
ніхто не знає скільки тренувань вони
пройдуть перед відправкою на фронт
цей підрозділ воює під бахмутом трохи
більше 20 кілометрів від цього полігону
біля міста Дружківка
бійці постійно ротуються на своїх
позиціях деякі з цих інструкторів щойно
прибули з фронту деякі ветерани
переходять до навчання новобранців тому
що у боях отримали настільки важкі
поранення що не змогли повернутися назад
звичайно
нюанс з людьми які судить по 5-6 років
по три роки То простіше було не треба
було стільки тратити на базу у
підготовку але рівень підготовки Я б не
сказав що
більше появилася командирів які можуть
підготувати особовий склад ну
на полігоні де тренується розвідувальний
взвод командир роти звикає до того що
замість досвідчених солдатів він тренує
новачків
Гуру це його позивний бачив як багато
його товаришів по службі отримували
поранення або гинули
важко сказати Я навіть Скажем так з тими
з ким починав вже багатьох немає хлопців
гинуть На жаль гинуть На жаль Офіцери
командирів взводів
гинуть головні сержанти гинуть сержанти
і їх досить багато
не хоче її рахувати Чесно це важко
Особисто я був два рази поранений так
само і тут загадувати і хто буде коли ну
це просто невідомо чесно
наш оператор отримав поранення під час
обстрілу коли ми вчимо до лікарні то
бачимо як солдати поспішають на допомогу
своїм пораненим товаришам пораненим ще
до того як вони потрапили на передову
після вторгнення Росії в Україну настрій
Латвії напружені ця сусідні з Росією
Україна колись входила до складу
Радянського Союзу поки не проголосила
свою незалежність
але Латвійська культура завжди
допомагала людям зберігати свою
ідентичність і спадщину особливо через
пісню і танець
кожні 5 років латвійці збираються разом
щоб провести фестиваль пісні і танцю
цього року в нього беруть участь армандс
народжений в Латвії та Аліна народжена в
Росії
зараз важкі часи особливо для Російської
меншини в Латвії але цей фестиваль
об'єднує всіх
як країна виражає свою свободу Єдність і
незалежність латвійський народ робить це
за допомогою пісні і танцю протягом
останніх 150 років Ця країна на березі
Балтійського моря кожні 5 років
проводить традиційний фестиваль пісні і
танцю
[музика]
[оплески]
деякі люди просто не можуть жити без
цього фестивалю
Я в принципі дуже зациклена На музиці
вона мене дуже наповнює І це просто у
крові Аліна з Росії а арманс і зла твій
дві культури в одній країні із
політичної точки зору це непроста пара
але на цьому фестивалі Це не має
значення тут вони всі один народ
[музика]
Але перед тим як розпочати шоу
виконавцям потрібно багато тренуватися
двічі на тиждень протягом п'яти років
для Російської співачки Аліни і гошевої
ці мелодії проклали шлях до Латвії у
1998 році вона вперше взяла участь у
фестивалі Коли ще жила у Москві але
родове коріння Аліни в Латвії
мама з дитинства приділяє цьому багато
уваги вона мене водила із семирічного
віку в Латвійське посольство в Москві і
там була надійна школа поки вона чекала
на мене то співала в хорі так власне
почалося моє захоплення латинською
культурою
[музика]
Через роки під час поїздки з хором до
риги Аліна закохалася в латвійську
столицю у 2014 році уродженка Москви
почала тут нове життя
сьогодні Аліна викладає в
латинсько-російський початковій школі
Якщо Аліна виражає свою латвійську
ідентичність через пісню то арманд через
танець
арманс рідельс вирощує обліпиху на
заході Латвії це його друга пристрасть
одразу після танців
коли ми її з сестрою були маленькими
батьки возили нас до олії паї на уроки
танців тоді нам доводилося їздити на
репетиції за 10 кілометрів і тоді танці
стали невід'ємною частиною мого життя
[музика]
незалежно від того наскільки Цей
фестиваль об'єднує людей війна Росії
проти України все ще створює напругу у
взаєминах між латвіцями та росіянами
невеликий відсоток людей російського
походження підтримує режим Путіна але
багато латвійців не звинувачують
російський народ у цій війні
Люди там не винні у війні проблеми
не в Росії а в керівництві
цивільне населення зараз не може
вплинути на ситуацію
їм не вистачає сміливості вийти на
вулицю і щось сказати
але нам латвійцям також знадобилися роки
щоб зайти так далеко і відновити свободу
завдяки співочій революції
Аліна теж каже що не тримає зла на
російській народ за війну їй також
небайдужа доля її старої батьківщини
Росії з государства
за державу завжди було образливо
тому що країна завжди подобається більше
ніж держава
я була активною позиціонеркою коли жила
там бігала помітингам потім у якийсь
момент я зрозуміла що це там не працює
на жаль а взагалі нічого не змінюється І
це тільки підкріпило моє бажання виїхати
сюди
до Латвії де співи танці не просто хобі
а основа Латвійської ідентичності
на цілий тиждень країна поринає у
фестиваль пісні і танцю
[оплески]
він розпочинається традиційними парадами
у старому місті риги завершується
грандіозним фінальним концертом
[музика]
напередодні спільного виступу Аліна та
арманс знайомляться особисто
Привіт Привіт
а вони співають до ранку Наступного дня
десятигодинне свято Надії впевненості та
підтримки
добробут тварин і традиції високо
цінуються але коли Справа доходить до
китобійного промислу ці цінності
суперечать один багато людей не
підтримують полювання на цих розумних
морських ссавців та їхнє вбивство проте
на фарерських островах люди дивляться на
це по-іншому тут загінне полювання на
китів має багатовікову традицію це
стосується і маленького селища ґоте для
місцевого жителя Йона роясона і тобі не
промисел ключова частина його життя і
він не думає відмовлятися від цього
Фарерські острови що височіють над
Північною атлантикою це суворість у
чистому вигляді
вони були утворені вулканічною
активністю близько 50 мільйонів років
тому їхні мешканці живуть завдяки морю
який досі залишається основним джерелом
їжі
18-річний йон Рой хегнесен виріс у
рибальському селі ґота він тренується в
селі то на старих грибних човнах перед
роботою у місцевому музеї цей музей
присвячений одній із найбільш
суперечливих традицій фарерських
островів полюванню на гринт
[музика]
для полювання на китів і він трохи
довший за звичайний рибальський ніж
але він не дуже ефективний тож коли кити
підпливали до берега потрібно було
просто встромити нішу голову кита і
сподіватися на краще
традиція полювання на китів має серйозну
історію Землі на цих островах мало і
вона майже неродюча тому протягом
багатьох століть жителів островів
змушені були Виходити у море
за допомогою простих грибних човнів вони
заганяли цих ссавців у Фіорди і вбивали
їх на мілководті фарерці і досі полюють
У такий спосіб тільки сьогодні вони
використовують іншу зброю ось цим
вбивають кита
і це дуже просто
Це набагато гуманніше чим ніж
Сподіваюся ця традиція проживе ще кілька
сотень років
міжнародні Захисники прав тварин
сподіваються на протилежне
члени товариства морський пастух прибули
на острови щоб зупинити полювання на
гринд
серед них Александра лечвар морська
біологія з Польщі
те що тут відбувається просто сумно це
те що на мою думку не повинно більше
відбуватися вони роблять це вже багато
років для них це традиція це те що вони
робили аби вижити проблема на наш погляд
у тому що в цьому більше немає
необхідності це зайві страждання для
тварин
активісти спробували зафільмувати
полювання за допомогою Дронів
ших речей це гонитва перед самим
полюванням яка може тривати годинами
Ви можете бачити як вони пливуть зараз
вже неспокійно і не вимушено Вони
тікають розумієте вони в страху
гринди належать до родини дельфінів вони
соціальні і живуть групами які
називаються зграями фарерці кажуть що
популяції дельфінів не перебувають під
загрозою зникнення як тільки фарерці
бачать зграю китів вони б'ють на сполох
селяни поспішають до своїх моторних
човнів щоб загнати з ссавців у глухий
кут
усе село чекає на березі чоловіки жінки
та діти Усі долучаються до роботи
разом Вони витягують китів на сушу
вибивати їх дозволено лише тим хто має
мисливську ліцензію
потім шестиметрових тварин розрубують на
шматки
Це полювання не комерційне китове м'ясо
роздають безкоштовно
це одне з небагатьох продуктів які ми
можемо отримати з місцевих джерел У нас
є картопля риба вівці і кити а все інше
імпортується
фарерці і сьогодні споживають м'ясо і
жир китів вони консервують його і
подають на стіл в особливих випадках
готує з нього щось на зразок гуляшу це
тут повсякденна їжа
щодня у світі бувають мільйони свиней ми
вбиваємо кілька Ну так десь 500 на рік а
всього Grand 500 тисяч чи десь так
їжа є їжа і ця їжа смачна
чи є традиційне полювання на фарерських
островах більш жорстоким ніж Фабрична
фермерство у багатьох інших країнах
зоозахисники з морського пастуха можуть
зрозуміти логіку такої позиції ці
тварини у них було хороше життя до цього
у багатьох тварин яких ми їмо як
суспільство цього не було їх просто
виростили щоб убити і ми так само не
вважаємо що те що вони роблять це
правильно на нашу думку це дуже
неправильно
Їхня місія на фарерських островах
ймовірно триватиме ще досить довго
припиняти полювання на китів і дельфінів
не планується
за цей рік тут убили вже близько
півтисячі тварин
[музика]
одне з найпопулярніших туристичних місць
Німеччини шпреївальд не лише для
іноземних гостей а для мешканців столиці
Берліна що знаходиться на подолік
це розлоги і води ландшафт де
відвідувачі люблять справлятися на
човнах по ідеїчних каналах і крихітних
річках якщо вони достатньо Та це місце
ризикує незабаром пересохнути причина
Однак не зовсім пов'язана з кліматичними
змінами а з політичними рішеннями
прийнятими в Берліні
таким мешканцям як діркмаєр вони
завдають сильного головного болю
дірк Майер у своїй стихії на воді тут у
північнонімецькому шпреї вальді пан Маєр
заробляє на життя керуючих готелями та
гаванню для човнів ця місцевість
приваблює багато туристів але пан Майер
знає шпреєвальд змінюється
Ми не можемо забувати що останні 50-60
років нам щастило у нас не було дефіциту
води навпаки У нас її було занадто
багато
ці часи минули у 2019 році рівень води в
шпреєвальді знизився канали та річки
пересохли тоді це було винятком через
спеку та відсутність дощів Але експерти
такі як іннгольф Арнольд попереджають це
може бути майбутнім спрайвальда
якщо ми нічого не зробимо вся система
зруйнується і це найбільший вплине наш
краєвальд
причина родовища бурого вугілля
неподалік а видобуток вугілля відкритим
способом передбачає риття величезних
кар'єрів ви викачування величезних
обсягів підземних вод раніше це
призводило до того що вода потрапляла у
шпреєкт але Німеччина припиняє видобуток
бурого вугілля а це означає що качати
воду більше не будуть а відповідно
більше не буде підземних вод які живлять
шпрея
щойно ми припинимо видобувати вугілля і
перестанемо викачувати підземні води Нам
доведеться жити з природними рівнем води
якщо влітку буде мало дощів малі річки
можуть пересохнути
вальд може стати таким яким він був до
початку видобутку вугілля Коли ліс іноді
переповнювався А іноді пересихав це може
мати наслідки для туризму та спричинити
інші проблеми
песимістичний сценарій на 25 років
вперед полягає в тому що посушливе літо
водний туризм буде дуже обмеженим
і Берліну фактично доведе ться нормувати
водопостачання
а зрештою шпрея протікає через Берлін і
використовується не лише для плавання на
човнах 40% питної води німецька столиця
отримує зі шпреї якщо рівень води значно
знизиться її може не вистачити екологи
вимагають негайно вжити рішучих заходів
у спрея-авальді щоб зберегти воду у
ландшафті
ми маємо захистити болота і засипати
канали які були розширені що вмістити
зайву воду з вугільних шахт А це
коштуватиме грошей
реставрація каналів може означати кінець
для багатьох популярних серед туристів
екскурсій на човнах шпреєвальдом
Це було б жахливо
це те що робить таким чудовим річки вода
і природа інші міста використовують
доходи від туризму Я сподіваюся що це
спрацює і тут Венеція тепер бере плату з
відвідувачів ми маємо зробити так само і
з одноденними туристами тут
Ми повинні зберегти унікальний характер
шприєвальду тому маємо знайти спільне
рішення разом з інженерами ландшафтним
архітекторами та екологами
на це безумовно потрібні чималі кошти
усі ідеї щодо порятунку шпреєвальду
дорогі і суперечливі одна із пропозицій
затопити старі шахти це створило
величезні озера подібні до котбуса Ост з
воду звідти Можна було б за потреби
відводити до шприц
площа цього озера охоплює близько двох
тисяч гектарів
глибини в якості резерву то можна
зберігати 20 мільйонів кубометрів води і
влітку подавати їх при авальд
але тоді ці озера мали б виглядати
зовсім інакше код буссер остдзеє не може
мати велику площу поверхні адже це
призводить до більшого випаровування
площа поверхні повинна бути маленькою а
глибина дуже великою
інша ідея полягає в тому щоб відвести
воду в прес прилеглих річок таких як
Одер але Одер також страждає від нестачі
води особливо влітку Не кажучи вже про
витрати
екологи вимагають щоб гірничодобувні
компанії взяли на себе більшу частину
тягаря а не держава на наше прохання
прокоментувати компанія ліах що
видобуває буре вугілля відповіла що вони
знають про дослідження експертів у
бранденбурзі заявили що поки зарано
ініціювати конкретні заходи а уряд
Берліна ще не оцінив ситуацію
та пан Маєр каже що час спливає
уже зараз запізно на реалізацію такого
планування піде ще 20 років ми знаємо
про це вже сто років і все одно нам
треба зібратися із думками
жителі жпроєвальду знають дні і
делічного лісу який вони називають домом
злічені і зміни неодмінно настануть
А зараз я хотів би познайомити вас з
британською музиканткою Анною лапфуд Ця
молда жінка пристрасна органістка і
регулярно грає в розкішному
королівському Альберт Холі найбільш
культовому музичному закладі Лондона
але коли Англія тут вона не чує Оплески
чи вигуків Браво це дивно адже є музичні
записи почула широка аудиторія по всьому
світу
що ж очевидно для Анни і небо не межа А
на сьогодні це все дякуємо за перегляд
Бережіть себе і до зустрічі в наступному
випуску Європа У фокусі
[музика]